that is the huge takeaway i've taken
from all these people is just an immense
amount of gratitude and
um
you know don't i mean everybody has a
bad day but
for sure
i'm sure martin lawrence had a bad day
dude
martin blew my mind i mean i've heard
stories of of martin from back in the
day
that man is
is really special i love him did you
ever see the movie life he's genius
yeah and he gave me the time of day like
you never would expect i remember when
we finished bad boys i bought them about
willa martinez like necklace that said
like bad boys on it was this gold
necklace that i had this like this
jewelry company engraved you know bad
boys on i gave one to my room with the
will and
martin wore it to the wrap party
you know and wow
yeah you know like he's just one you
know
he's just such a good dude and his
buddies that he's his sister is amazing
the buddies that he surrounds himself
with they're all so i don't know what he
was like back in the day but whatever
whatever it was i i had nothing i have
nothing but incredible things to say
about them and he's just so lovely and
just was there to work i remember he i
was a guest on conan o'brien and
he was the main guest and i was just
sitting in my you know room kind of a
little nervous you know right before and
also there's a knock on the door
and it opens up and it's martin lawrence
i'm like because i had told somebody i'm
like oh i'm a big martin lawrence fan
and he looks at me he's like hey man
what's up and i go hey dude he's like
hey you do your thing on there man you
do your thing on there and i'm like you
know he just came over gave me a hug and
then i quoted the movie life and you go
i just said something like oh damn ray i
got my big toe caught in a bottle
and he just started lives what how do
you know that you know he just like is a
random random quote from this movie and
he was so sweet that's why i thought
because i heard stories too but my
meeting with him he went out of his way
to be kind so i hear you
i love that and like imagine like then
that's the other thing is like i think
it's really important to hold judgment
until you meet somebody in person
because yeah like
imagine if everyone was watching you
all hours of the day i mean we've all
had a bad day at a supermarket or at a
[ __ ] gas station i mean like we you
know what i mean like the difference is
that this has become so public i think
um
i can't imagine that that kind of toll
it would take on you so
i mean i absolutely love marty marr i
can't wait to work with him